foreign
[Silence]
thank you you you read my mind
and my bad
continuing with where we left off last
week
with the
causes
for a person's heart
to become open and accepting
to the light
and the quran and the sunnah the light
of allah
amen
what opens the heart we discuss some of
these things
we're at the fourth part
and last week we discussed
the statement of ibn al-qaeda
and loving him with the entirety of your
heart
and we discussed a very important detail
with regards to love
we discussed a very important detail
we said there's two types of love
natural love
and
religious love
correct
we said natural love
does not contradict religious love
but if you are in a position
to give precedence to one or the other
religious love must always
be first
okay
now let's unpack that a little
bit we said natural love
doesn't have anything to do with
religion correct
natural love
for example
we
as
muslim men
are allowed to marry non-muslim women
correct
there's nothing funny about that
okay
please
we are allowed to marry non-muslim women
christian jewish
according to the conditions allah
stipulated in surat al-maidah
okay
now
when a person marries this non-muslim
woman
is he not going to love her
is correct
yeah
he's gonna love her
hopefully
right
now how do we how do we harmonize
between that and the statement of allah
do
you mean
that you will not find a people
who
believe in allah in the last day
that will have love
for those who
are enemies to allah and his messenger
meaning non-muslims
how do we harmonize those two
because allah said
in surah
that the key thing that he placed
between a man and his wife is
right
he placed between them
so if you marry a non-muslim woman
you're going to have moeda
how do we harmonize between that and
that it is impermissible to love those
who are
those who are enemies to allah and his
messenger meaning those who are
disbelievers
any disbeliever even if that enmity is
shown and expressed in aggression or
that enmity is the mere fact that you
disbelieve in the quran in sunnah this
is called
this is called enmity towards allah and
his messenger you have called the
prophet salallahu sallam essentially a
liar you have said that he is
a liar the quran is not true the quran
is not the words of allah and this this
this man is not a messenger he is a
charlatan that's essentially what what
you're saying
when a person disbelieves in the message
of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
correct
so how do we harmonize those two
there's a lot of talk floating around
that those two verses are speaking about
the same type of love and that's where
the mistake comes in
those two verses are not speaking about
the same type of love
those two verses are speaking about two
different types of love
one is speaking about religious love
the other is speaking about
natural love
right a person's mother a person's
father a person's child is a non-muslim
they naturally love them naturally the
prophet muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam naturally loved his uncle who
died as a disbeliever correct
naturally loved them
so he loved him allah said you cannot
guide those whom you love rather it is
allah who guides whom he chooses
so the verse is
mentioning that he loved
abu talib
but did he love him in a religious
capacity
no he loved him in a
natural capacity
now let's flip that
those who love the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam in a natural capacity
okay
like
the disbelievers from amongst quraish
they all loved the prophet salallahu
even after he was a prophet
they loved they couldn't help but love
him he was truthful he was honest he was
generous he was brave he was
how can you not love someone that
right
he said to the prophet sallallahu alaihi
by allah you are upon great monumental
character
right
but they loved him
did that love benefit them with allah
did that love benefit them with allah no
why because that was what
natural love
correct
it was natural love
contrary to
religious love
is when you love someone
for the sake of allah even if you
haven't met them
so we love abu bakr and
uthman and all of the companions and we
love all of the taberine and all of the
scholars of islam even if we don't know
their names even if we haven't met them
correct
that's called religious love
and there is no problem with having
natural love
for those who do not
outwardly fight against allah and his
messenger
however
there are times
when religious love
and natural love clash
you have to choose one
one over the other
with
the prophet sallallahu alaihi
perfect example
he loved abu talib not
but he did not love him
that is reserved only for the muslims
and so
when abu talib died
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
was prohibited from making dua for him
[Silence]
there's no contradiction there
so abu talib passes away
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
implores him to say
and i will
i will use it as as
as a as a bargaining tool
before allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
to try to save you from hell
and his final words were
he said
i die upon thee
religion and the way
of abdul muttalib meaning my people and
their idolatry
so that is a disbeliever correct
when that happened the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam said
as he was mourning his death
he said
i swear by allah i will continue to make
dua for you
as long as allah does not prohibit me
from doing so
then the verse from surah tituba was
revealed
yesterday
then the verse was revealed in surah
it is not permissible for the prophets
or those who believe
to make
and seek forgiveness on behalf
of the disbelievers
after it has been made clear to them
that they are of the people of hell
even if they are
close relatives of theirs
so
what happened here
we have natural love and we have
religious love
now he has to choose one of the one or
the other
which one takes precedence
religious love
this
is the subtle difference between natural
and religious love
am i making sense
very good
because many people confuse those two
things
they confuse natural and religious love
so the disbelievers of quraish
they love the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam naturally
but they hated him what
religiously that's why they wanted to
kill him correct
the companions
they loved naturally their uncles and
their fathers and their sons and so
forth
but when they met them in battle what
happened
they
fought against them
in battle
and there were casualties
why
because
if religious love
and natural love cannot be harmonized
religious love may must always
must always
take precedence
this is why
allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
it is only the believers that are truly
brothers
right
because no matter what your natural love
will die with you
and on the day of resurrection
your love will be taught purely
religious love
you love what allah loves
and you
do not love what allah does not love
right
so your neighbor
okay
he's nice to you he mows your lawn he
takes out your trash whatever he
you know
brings your kids candy he
you know shovels your snow he's just
a nice guy
wouldn't you naturally love somebody
that
yeah you would
and if he got sick wouldn't you go visit
him
yeah
however
religiously
would you love this person
as long as they are a disbeliever
religiously
what do we say
no religiously no
religious love is reserved only for the
believers
correct
okay
so when we say
when ibn al-qayyam here
allah says turning to allah and loving
him with all of the heart he's speaking
about all of the religious heart
the part of your heart which is reserved
religious love
religious actions
not natural things
right
you naturally love food you naturally
love a cold drink of water on a hot day
you naturally love
this is natural loaf
right you naturally love your parent you
naturally love your child you naturally
love
comfortable things
however
you do not religiously love these things
in a way that will take you away from
allah
in a way that will cause you to disobey
and these things sometimes in the heart
become
they cross each other
so a person will start to love another
person in a way that is
unhealthy in a way that is obsessive in
a way that is religious
and that kind of love is reserved only
for allah subhanahu wa
so an example of somebody
who's religious love is
is contradicting his natural love
and they're starting to
impede on each other
is when a person loves their child for
instance and their child is an evil
person
and a disbeliever
and maybe goes out and
you know
leaves islam and goes and
becomes a a a a speaker against islam
and insults the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam insults allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
and preaches against islam and fights
against islam
yet
they love their child so much that they
support their child in this or
they sympathize with their child in this
this now is a major sin
why is it a major sin because now
your natural love
has crossed over into the religious part
of your heart
and that is unacceptable
that is when
a person's heart
hypocrisy will enter into it
clear clear clear clear as day correct
some some people say
how is it possible
that you can hate someone religiously
but love them
naturally it's very possible
right
because it's two different parts of the
heart
it's two different parts of the heart
and hatred
is the opposite of what
what is hatred the opposite of
love correct
just day is the opposite of what
night
so if it's not daytime what is it
so we can't play games with words
right
[Silence]
he said
not only turning to allah and loving
allah with all of the heart
but as well
completely
concentrating your
love
towards allah devoting yourself to him
entirely
and
finding solace in his worship
finding solace in
worshiping allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
finding comfort
finding pleasure
in the worship of allah
says some of us when we come to salas
just come on let's get this over
with you
[Silence]
he
foreign
he says that you are as well to find
solace
and comfort in the worship of allah
many of us for example salah when we
make salah it's just begrudgingly
yellow just prayed come on let's finish
huh
and we hear it all the time yeah
ma'am all the time is hearing it
[Silence]
foreign
my
he says here that
also a person must find peace and
comfort
in the worship of allah what does that
mean
peace and comfort in the worship of
allah
many of us
do not experience this very often
we may experience this
seldomly and sparingly
finding peace in allah's worship
finding solace in allah's worship
feeling a sense of tranquility in
allah's worship
what is tranquility in allah's worship
and solace and comfort
that is
that when it comes time let's take an
example of salah but it could be
anything else but salah
many of us begrudgingly drag ourselves
to prayer
and when the imam starts to recite the
quran
we listen which surahs he's reciting
oh my god he's reciting that surah that
one is a long one
yamaha
foreign
they will count the minutes
that the imam is leading them in salah
methalene
and it's not because the imam's voice is
terrible
i've prayed behind some some people
whose voice is terrible
the way they read the quran is not
correct
okay
so you are not
enjoying anything of the salah that's
a different story i'm talking about a
well-recited person who leads salah
why are we staring at the clock
oh it's suppose you're supposed to end
it just 10 minutes it was 11 minutes
this time
one sh one time off it was 11 minutes
i'm going to catch the shaykh and tell
him
he went too long it was 11 minutes this
time
huh
subhanallah
they have audacity
you just led them in
you just recited allah's book to them
and
they will tell you
you want one minute over you want two
minutes over
as if you have done a major crime don't
do this again this is haram
right
and then after they tell you that they
get it off their chest
they go in the back and they talk and
talk and talk and talk and talk until
they get kicked out
so it's the lights are all turned
off you have to leave you can't you
can't stay here you don't have to go
home but you can't stay here kind of
thing
then they go stand outside and talk and
talk and talk and talk and talk
that's fine
it's fine to speak and socialize with
your friends and so forth
right
what's not okay
is to be
in a state of
discomfort
when you stand to make salah
when you stand and make salah and you're
listening to a recitation that is a
reasonable recitation of the quran you
should be losing yourself in that
recitation
what do i mean by losing yourself
few of us have ever experienced it
losing yourself so deeply
allah was reciting
and praying
and a scorpion came and stung him in his
foot
a scorpion
stung him in his foot
and he kept praying as his foot was
swelling
until he finished the sale
so why didn't you
finish salah quickly
he said i was in the middle of a surah
and i didn't want to break it off
halfway through
right yeah
another example some of the companions
if they had to have some kind of major
surgery
they didn't have anesthesia at the time
right to the point where
they would stand for prayer
in order for a part of their body to be
cut off
a foot or a hand
because when they stood for salah they
had built the discipline
that
they are in a completely different realm
they're in a different world
and
they would not be able to feel the pain
as they would if they were present
now honestly speaking how many of us
have felt that way in saleh
right
forget cutting off your hand or or
getting stung by a scorpion if your
phone just vibrates
that's it so that's done
if it vibrates in the first rakah the
rest of the three that
are gone huh
they're gone up i wonder who that was i
wonder who that is i wonder if it's this
bird i know i've been waiting for a call
let me finish it i gotta get
call us the mind is gone
because we are so attached to
the illusion of this world
now the question comes
okay
you have discussed to us the problem
that we
how do we fix that problem
as we've mentioned many many times
all of these things all of these aspects
of islam
they are actually what
disciplines
correct
what is the definition of a discipline
a discipline
is something that you train yourself to
do
it gets stronger with practice
and it gets weaker with negligence
that's what discipline is
discipline
is something that you force yourself to
do
it's a type of discomfort
you force yourself to do it
and
it gets stronger
with practice
and gets weaker with
negligence
if you neglect it
it gets weak
and if you practice it it gets strong
so what does that mean
just a muscle
just a muscle in your body
the more you
practice and exercise this muscle the
stronger it
gets but
there's not a point where you reach
and you say that's it i'm enough i'm
going to be a muscular man for the rest
of my life no
if you stop exercising that
muscle it will start to what
it will start to deteriorate and it will
start to atrophy
and so that's what discipline is
discipline
is the ability to
stand for prayer
and force your mind
to focus on allah and allah alone
and at first when you start this process
your mind is going to wander and you're
going to pull it back by its collar
and every time it wanders you pull it
back by its collar
until
over time
it will become less and less difficult
you will have strengthened that
discipline
but
if you start to neglect it
and you start to
not exercise it it can also go away
meaning that
if you become very concentrated in your
prayer you have a lot of hoshur you are
to the point of almost mastery if you
stop practicing
it will go away
this is why we have a narration
where the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said
[Silence]
if a person stands for prayer
and his mind does not wander once
throughout those two raka'
what is past of his sins will be
forgiven
it sounds easy right
no not very easy
that why has his sins been forgiven
because it took him
years to develop that
strength of mind to be able to
lose himself in prayer so thoroughly
that
he will not even
stray in his mind from what he is doing
in prayer not even one time
from the beginning of prayer all the way
till the end
just two
how long does it take to make two deca
what three four minutes
make it a speedy two that got two
minutes
can you focus for two minutes and not
think about anything else other than
this
if you can what is past of your sins has
been forgiven
that's the promise of the prophet
easier said than done
why
because this takes years of practice
and some people are stronger than others
they develop faster
maybe it takes months of practice for
some
one of the taberine he said
[Silence]
is
was mentioned to have said
i spent 20 years
practicing
and struggling with prayer
and then after those 20 years
i was given another 20 where i enjoyed
prayer
what does that mean
that means that the first 20 years he
spent
fighting with himself
every single day no matter what his mood
was no matter what his problems were no
matter what was happening in his life no
excuses i have to do this
and then after that 20 years finally his
nephs
was subdued
and he gained the discipline and he
gained the strength to be able to
stand for prayer and
enjoy it
how many of us enjoy our prayer
how many of us
lose ourselves
between the verses of allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala
where you're listening to the quran so
deeply
that you forget
the world for a moment it doesn't occur
to you
time stops
and you are nowhere but with allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala this is what is
meant by
very bad
this
is a sure-fire way
that your heart will be open to the
quran and sunnah to develop that
discipline
that is enough for tonight
foreign